[Music]
we often tend to think of physical and
material things as the ultimate stuff of
the universe and yet contemporary
physics has largely abandoned the
physical description of things in favor
of energy and fields and yet many
philosophers have had a belief that
materialism is a profound mistake and
have challenged a physic list view of
the nature of reality
so should we give up our conviction that
physical stuff is the bedrock of the
world or is such stuff just in the end
unavoidable now I have joining me on
this panel to discuss this on my
immediate right I have Nancy Cartwright
Nancy Cartwright made very many
important contributions on the nature of
laws of causation causal inference
scientific models the unity of science
and in particular her work in social
science on my immediate left we have
subir sacker who's the head of particle
particle physics group at the University
of Oxford and an affiliated professor at
the Niels Bohr Institute also on my far
life we have John Duprey who is a
philosopher assigns and the former
president of the British society for the
philosophy of science and he's currently
the director of the Centre for the study
of life sciences at Exeter University so
I'm going to invite each of my panelists
to set out their stall in a 3 minute
section and we're really starting with
the question of whether we should give
up on our conviction that physical stuff
is the bedrock of the world so John
could you start us off please ok thank
you about
yeah I'm feels like quite strange
starting this off because I'm the one
person on the panel who doesn't know
much about physics and I guess some
degree this is a question about physics
so but I'm a philosopher so I will at
least start by gesturing towards
deconstructing the question I'm not
quite sure what bedrock means
in the question it might just mean
that's in some very strange sense all
there is that some of there's only
whatever physicists talk about whether
it's things or stuff or it might is
often taken to mean something much
stronger that somehow whatever the
physics says there is determines
everything else and makes everything
else - somehow less interesting I there
is a lot of discussion among
philosophers of science about whether
something like the latter is true but I
think we're going to largely avoid that
or at least have avoid that directly and
so so then I'm gonna come from a
different point in here's my store the
problem I see with talking about things
is that at least from my perspective
interesting biology I don't think there
are any things anywhere at any scale I
think what we talk about that when we
talk about things we're talking about
stable parts of processes and the
underlying kind of philosophical idea is
that much more fundamental than the old
question what a thing is is the question
what it does and actually activity doing
happening acting are the most
fundamental constituents of the universe
I I guess one way of saying that is to
have a picture of what the history of
the universe is like the the universe I
guess began and again here this is a
question for physicists and cosmologists
but I guess it began pretty much as pure
energy or mass energy or something like
that but over the billions of years that
have followed various different things
have emerged I want to see those things
and as not objects in the traditional
sense in which we think of sort of
billiard ball atoms and things made up a
billiard ball atoms but as Eddy is in a
flow of process and I think the Eddy in
a stream is the perfect kind
of paradigm for what actually these
things alike
when we understand when we look at that
a whole lot of things make much more
sense from this point of view as soon as
we get start to get any kind of
structures out of this evolutionary
process new forms of activity become
possible so even just chunks of matter
an asteroid condensed a planet that's
something that I get pure energy
there's no denting going on there I'm of
course I guess then we have chemical you
know the evolution of chemical objects
things and what becomes possible then
there's all kinds of interactions which
underlay eventually the emergence of
life which is of course my particular
interest as we have life and we have
living processes Eddie's in a stream of
immensely complex chemistry structured
in various ways we have countless new
activities things or processes that swim
that can fly that can mate that can eat
and so on and I think we have another
stage of this complexity actually with
the appearance of humans who do a lot
more than any other creatures in terms
of new kinds of activities that
constitute us as humans and of course
many of those are focused around
language culture the things we always
like to talk about as being very special
about ourselves but but the you know and
and I guess you know it as up here
people like us tend to think I'd rather
high up on this hierarchy of things we
do as debate deep philosophical
questions now I don't think debating
deep philosophical questions at any rate
is something that matter does qua matter
it's something that very complex arrays
of matter arranged into the kind of
dynamic streams that we are is capable
of and so far as we know nothing else
has done this picture nothing in this
picture is supposed to appeal to
what might traditionally have been
thought of as non-physical stuff now of
course all these complex things that
emerge in the evolution of the universe
are not physical in the sense of being
whatever it is that physics talks about
but but they're not non-physical in the
sense that I take it that all of these
things are insofar as they're made of
something made of whatever physics talks
about the the whole that the thrust of
what I'm saying is that being made of is
not a particularly fundamental or
bedrock aspect of something the fact
that we're made of ultimately the same
stuff as rocks or giraffes or whatever
else doesn't tell you anything very much
the kind of activities that we are
capable of that make us human are very
different John thank you so that's a
very broad prospectus we've got all the
way from the eddies in the stream to I
think I heard you mention asteroids and
planets and all these other things which
might tempt us to think about discrete
parts of the stuff and we'll come back
to that I'm sure but it severely turned
to you with the same question if we're
thinking that there's a physical stuff
that's the sort of underlying stuff of
everything else there is what is it like
okay so I've been do a little debate
this morning so I've learned that you
don't answer the question you tell a
story first so I'm going to do that by
saying bit apprehensive about appearing
on a panel with philosophers because I'm
a physicist especially since one of my
companions here rude a book called why
the laws of physics lie which is rather
subtle it puts me in my place so let me
say that I was reminded of a story that
Helen Dukas was Einsteins long-term
secretary she wrote a biography of him
she recounts that she once asked him to
come to a talk which was being given on
the philosophy of his theory of special
relativity
and Einstein sort of hums and holes and
says a bit busy and Jesus but her
Einstein no no it's on the philosophy of
your new theory surely you are
interested and he says you know when I
go to these talks I feel I'm swallowing
something I don't have in my mouth now
I'm sure that's not going to be the case
today
so my response to this question which is
should we give up on our conviction that
the physical stuff is the bedrock of the
world question mark is to invoke
something we call hinge Cliff's rule in
physics Ian Hinchcliffe is a physicist
at Berkeley and his rule is that if
there is a title of his scholarly
article is a yes/no question the answer
is always no okay now of course you can
ask is hinge cliffs rule true right so
there is a paradox there of course we
all know the hinge crease really is true
except when it is not right so it
doesn't apply to the three themes of
this meeting is reality made of matter
answer is okay to the things forget so
this question the answer is no the
answer is no so physical stuff is not
the bedrock of the world give up on it
should give up on it good for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you